Here's the result of
the entire post condition for
the permutation function.
Okay, we'll say that X is
a permutation of Y, if and
only if one of the three,
any one of the three cases hold.
The first case was that the vector
was empty, then it's a permutation.
Or the second case was if
it's non empty and the first
elements are the same then it's
a permutation if the tails are the same,
and the third case was it's non empty,
the first elements don't match,
and there is some place
in the output vector Y,
where the first element does occur, and
we're going to call that position J,
and it's then the case that there's
a permutation between the tail of X and
the results of pasting together
the segment before the J position
with the segment that comes
after the J position.
Please make sure you
understand this example.
It's the toughest bit of specification
we'll see in these lessons.
And it's important for you if you're
going to be able to express things
precisely that you understand how we
approach this particular problem.
>> I think that second case was, you
said the first elements in both X and
Y hold, and
then the remaining tails of both X and
Y are permutations of each other.
Not the same as each other like,
is that okay?
>> So, you got me there.
And but, one of the points we're making
with this is that same elements as is,
the same thing as permutation.
>> Okay.
So, I did state it incorrectly.